تبدو اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق النار هناك مجرد
حبر على ورق ليس الا فمنذ اندلاع الازمه
السودانيه لم تمر اي هدنه دون ان يكسر او
يكسر صمتها ذوي اطلاق النار الحال لم
يختلف في اول اتفاق رسمي لاطلاق النار
فرغم دخوله حيز التنفيذ الى ان اصوات
الرصاص والغارات الجويه سمعت في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وبعيدا عن اتفاق اطلاق
او وقف اطلاق النار اتهمت وزاره الصحه في
ولايه الخرطوم اتهمت الدعم السريع
بالتمركز في المستشفيات وقالت في بيان لها
ان الدعم السريع واصل لاستهداف المستمر
للقطاع الصحي بكل مكوناته واستهداف المرضى
والكوادر الصحيه وتبع البيان ان عدد
المستشفيات التي تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع ارتفع الى 28 مستشفى وست مؤسسات
صحيه حيويه مشيرا الى انها تستولي ايضا
على احدى وعشرين عربه اسعاف
تبعاتها الحرب على الاوضاع الانسانيه بدات
تتجلى اكثر فاكثر مع استمرار المعارك وهو
ما دفع العديد من المنظمات الدوليه الى دق
ناقوس الخطر من بينها مفوضيه الامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين التي حذرت من ان
عدد الذين يلجاون الى تشاد هربا من
السودان يتزايد بسرعه كبيره اضافت
المفوضيه ان عدد الاشخاص الذين فروا من
السودان نحو تشاد بات يتراوح ما بين 60
و90 الف شخص كما دعت المفوضيه الى ضروره
نقل الوافدين الجدد الى تشاد الى اقرب
مخيمات للاجئين بشكل عاجل خصوصا مع اقتراب
موسم الامطار
هذا وقالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
لديها ادوات للتعامل مع انتهاك وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان ولن تتردد باستخدام تلك
الادوات في الوقت المناسب اوضح المتحدث
باسم الوزاره ماثيوميلر ان واشنطن ومجموعه
مراقبه الهدنه بالسودان تناقش مزاعم
انتهاك وقف النار
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات